Mars used to look a lot like Earth.
The planet had a vast sea under oxygen rich
skies, and as far as we know, all the right
conditions for life.
But while Earth was beginning to see its first
glimpse of life, Mars was losing its chance
of becoming a habitable world.
We don’t know why, but roughly 4.2 billion
years ago, Mars’s magnetic field disappeared.
That magnetic field protected the young planet
from a constant barrage of solar winds ejected
from the sun, but once it was gone...
Mars’s warmer, rich atmosphere was blown
out of the solar system…
And all that’s left now, is the rocky, cold,
and uninhabitable planet we know today.
But could we make Mars habitable again?
NASA might have a new strategy to do just
that.
They theorize that by placing a large magnetic
dipole shield between Mars and the Sun, they
can protect the planet from the Sun’s solar
winds and perhaps establish a new atmospheric
equilibrium.
Mars would live in the dipole’s magnetotail
essentially restoring its lost magnetosphere,
giving the planet a chance to reestablish
its long lost atmosphere.
NASA’s simulations show that as the atmosphere
thickens, Mars’s climate would become 4
degrees Celsius warmer, enough to melt the
carbon dioxide ice at the polar cap.
The carbon in the atmosphere would then trap
heat, creating a greenhouse effect that could
give Mars back its liquid water and allow
for a better chance of a habitable planet.
This, of course, is theoretical, and seems
rather fanciful, but there is already research
underway into miniature magnetospheres that
may one day protect humans and spacecrafts
on deep space missions.
So it’s not inconceivable to apply that
technology on a larger scale.
And NASA has stated that if this can be achieved
in a lifetime, the colonization of Mars would
not be far away.
Scientists are trying to predict the future
of our own protective magnetic shield.
Click here to find out what’s in store for
us here on Earth.